What do you want me to say?
Or, more importantly, how
do you want me to say it?
I could stand here and
narrate my world to you
like it's the opening
credits of a disaster movie.
This is the setup.
2050, far enough in the future
for all this to seem plausible.
Climate catastrophe reported
as normality, the daily index
of maximum time
allowed outside in Doha
or Austin or Manchester.
In all these places, it is
over 50 degrees centigrade.
If you go outside for more
than your allotted hour,
then you will die.
Some specific new tragedy.
Targeted bioweapon
takes out Cape Town
as the statelets of a collapsed
South Africa fight for water.
First use of live ammunition
to keep the hordes out
on the Italian/Swiss border.
I could be a newsreader,
if we still have those.
A citizen journalist,
screaming into a phone
against the backdrop of
burning old growth forest.
Ported into your optic nerve
through a neural network,
a studio improvised
in a spare bedroom
to half a billion subscribers.
But not anything we'd recognise
as TV news, or newspapers,
obviously.
Whatever a newspaper
looks like then,
we're probably
imagining it wrong.
Whatever happens,
whatever lies look like,
whatever truth becomes, it
probably won't look like this.
This isn't really the future.
This is an idea of the
future that by the time
you're watching it is
in the past anyway.
This is what the future looked
like in our heads in 2019.
I'm just here saying, how do
you want me to talk to us?
Should we talk about
dystopia, maybe?
But dystopia is weird, isn't it?
It feels now like we might
have made a mistake about it.
Depending on which version
of this future world
I'm in right now, of course.
I mean, maybe we scared
ourselves a bit too much.
All that footage
of rising oceans,
and rioting in the
cities, and the streets
of London underwater,
and one filthy
polar bear that was all
ribs, and hunger, and sadness.
All those water
wars, desiccated dead
piled in the uninhabitable
streets, and the rise of idiots
feeding on fear with
simplistic solutions.
A lot of that happened.
Or from where you're
watching this, a lot of that
is going to happen.
The processes are in motion.
Dengue fever's gearing
up for a world tour.
Extreme heat's
eyeing up more people
than just the old
or young or sick.
People are dying of
this stuff right now.
But if that's what
we tell ourselves,
we internalise the
end, the idea of it.
We lie down in the face of
it because it's just too big,
and then that is the end.
Because we'll put our trust, our
need to be saved from all that,
in things we can't see yet.
We'll take the chance of an
off-moment of inspiration
over the provable reality.
It's just the way we're built.
The big discoveries of
self-regenerating bodies,
and fusion power, and
everything quiet, and humming,
and electric.
Bringing the global
temperature down
with sulphates or electric cars
or some method of clean energy
we haven't even thought of yet.
Our ability to
pull salvation out
of the apocalypse hat at
the last minute, to carbon
capture our way out of this.
The idea there's a
sole solution that
will save us through the
power of eureka is seductive.
And we're trying
all these things.
We are.
But whatever
arrives, if it does,
it can't reach back
through time to now.
We've never really worked
out how to talk about this.
We probably should have.
I mean, it's not as
if we didn't know.
Even if some of us took
comfort in the voices
that only told us what
we wanted to hear.
And then we spent a long time
trying to blind ourselves
with science, and we're sorry.
That didn't necessarily work.
Graphs.
Graphs, red lines, colours,
and concentrations,
parts per million, and rises
of degrees, and millimetres.
And we look around ourselves
and think, don't we?
These numbers are too small
or too large or meaningless.
What does 2 degrees
mean on a cold day?
And what does it mean
decades from now?
Which of them is easier
to feel in our bones
and then get on with our lives?
If we could have sung
scientific facts like pop songs,
we'd have got to the chorus
sooner, but we didn't.
It's not that we
could have stopped
these things from happening.
But we'd have been better
prepared to face them
in a way that didn't
kill so many of us.
Maybe we screwed
ourselves up with too much
speculative fiction.
I could be standing
at the edge of the sea
telling you the future
looks like this,
that most of the
streets you grew up in
are behind me in the waves.
List the countries
that are gone,
and the parts of countries,
because they're underwater
or you just can't
go outside in them,
where the local
biospheres collapsed,
show you the normal
life that plays out
against that backdrop.
A kind of warmer, more
beige version of now
with potholes and soldiers
on the streets everywhere,
rather than just
the poor places.
And only three
types of toothpaste.
Thing is, when you make the
argument about lifestyle
degrading, you either
don't want to believe it
because you think you're
immune, or you don't care,
because you're
already living it.
But the one thing nobody
told us was that everything
was going to be all right.
Nobody serious, anyway.
And if that's what you heard,
it wasn't what we were saying.
We never found the way to
make ourselves do enough,
fast enough.
I mean, some of us, yes.
But doing enough
consistently, talking
in a way that made
this possible to grasp
in the quiet parts of life in
the times between the times
that we all march, no.
We needed to make this
as everyday as bath time.
As graspable as pre-packed
sandwiches or your loved
one's hand.
And we didn't.
Every time we tried to make
the defining statement,
we thought, maybe
this is the one.
Maybe this is the one
that gets through.
We didn't need data or heroes.
We didn't even need
voices pretending
to be from the future.
We're in the same place.
It's not about our children
or our grandchildren anymore.
The future has come to meet us.
Most of the people watching this
will be there when it happens.
We needed to
understand, quietly,
every day, that
this is the future--
now.
Every single second.
We're not waiting
for the future.
We're not trying to fend it off.
We're living in it.
It is now.
And it is us.